foreign
[Music]
everybody my name is Chad Jennings and I
wanted to say thank you very much for
spending a little bit of time with us I
realize that we occupied that critical
hour between the end of a long day and
happy hour so I won't say we're gonna go
really fast but I will say we're going
to be really interesting so setting the
bar high for our speakers
um our goal with the talk we have three
and they are we're gonna review the
geospatial analytics Suite inside of
Google cloud and what our investment
Theses and philosophy philosophies have
been
then we have resulting from those
Investments we have two really
outstanding things to launch which Emily
is going to take care of and then we
have not one but two customers to come
up and talk to you about their Journey
so if we're successful with all three of
these goals what I'd like to leave you
with is a feeling of both inspiration
and reassurance that as you tackle these
really gnarly questions around
sustainability and climate change that
Google cloud and our ecosystem of
Partners and the other experienced
customers out there have got you covered
so that's what we're on about let's go
ahead and get started so to accomplish
those three goals we have four people
right that's an over constrained set so
we should be good
um Emily and I'll run you through the
product stuff and then Jeremy and Martin
will come up and talk about what their
companies have done using the things
that we're launching in like you know 10
minutes or as soon as I stop talking
um if you are watching this online you
can use this Glide to navigate the video
for the rest of us here we really don't
need it because you all are stuck
so let's go ahead and get started here
I'm going to set the stage just a little
bit and so all of us as data analytics
minded folks have been totally consumed
with one topic over the last year and
that is generative AI
right it's everywhere it's everywhere in
this constant in this conference and to
be honest it's right it came and it
disrupted much of the work and much of
our priorities for the first half of
this year
however that's for the analytics
industry if you search for Google Trends
and you look at generative Ai and all
the related subtopics and climate change
and all the related subtops subtopics
you'll see that climate change is 6 to
10 times more prevalent than anything
around generative AI so while we are
focused on gen AI large language models
how do we incorporate these effectively
how do we incorporate these responsibly
the rest of the world like planet Earth
and most of the people on it are
concerned about other stuff they're
concerned about climates and it's not
unreasonable to see why because it's
getting hot it's getting hotter and I'm
I won't spend a lot of time motivating
this here but I did want to show you
these two pieces of data so the chart on
the right
um speakers right here your left I guess
um shows the daily Global air
temperature
since 1979 through to the first half of
2023. so the light gray lines are 1979
through 2021 the dark gray line is 2022
which was the hottest year on record up
until
anyone
up until probably 2023 right we look
like we're gonna take that record away
the article on the left side here or
sorry your uh viewer is right
um you know this isn't just a result of
the natural stochasticity of you know of
our planet right we are causing this
change and so as we are changing the
world businesses have to adapt to this
new environment and so businesses
priorities are changing in response so
governments are trying to figure out
what new ESG reporting metrics are
important and when are they due and when
do those metrics get businesses the
proper considerations in their
Industries insurance companies are
trying to figure out how to manage the
new and higher magnification of
hurricanes right the one coming to
Florida right now the one that just
happened in La hurricanes in La really
yeah
so insurance companies are having to
Grapple with this financial institutions
are trying to calculate the portfolio
investment risk due to climate change
public sector is trying to figure out
how to manage road infrastructure
Bridges now that they're actually being
submerged in and drying out far more
often than is used to happen so really
the question of where is sustainability
and where is climate change
driving need for new analytics the
answer is pretty much everywhere
and so
if you have a platform your platform
needs to have three specific qualities
to answer this challenge those three
qualities are oh sorry I got ahead of
myself
um
when you've got sorry let me back up a
little bit wrong slide
um
when you've got needs that are this
prevalent in this omnipresent in the
world
you start to get input and demands from
two places one is the very top of your
funnel right governments are setting up
new
um you know Governors are setting up new
uh reporting processes and your
customers are asking for new answers and
so when you're getting squeezed from
both the top and the bar both the top
and the bottom your entire company needs
to respond and if your entire company
needs to respond you can bet the board
will want to respond and if the board
wants to respond then you'd better have
a good strategy
so here you go
the strategy around sustainability
really has two aspects to it one of them
first and foremost it's a data challenge
right we've never been through this
before so we have to do research to
figure out what we're up against right
that's a data challenge the second one
is a cultural Challenge and when you put
these two together Google feels like it
is very well positioned to have
significant impact here because if you
have the right data infrastructure and
if your data infrastructure has the
right capabilities then you can build
the right culture to be collaborative
and to be Innovative and to be fast
so here are the three fundamental
characteristics that your data
infrastructure really needs
you need massive and ready to go
geospatial data catalogs you need
immense storage capability and a lot of
computes and fortunately the geospatial
analytics Suite that I'm going to talk
about here is really built to highlight
these three particular capabilities as
well as it's designed around the two
major data types that geospatial
analytics uses so here's our analytics
Suite
the um the Suites built on four products
the pillars are primarily four products
bigquery for Vector analysis Earth
engine for raster analysis vertex AI for
access to all the Fantastic apis that
they're producing and then Google Maps
platform for sharing and communication
of the results that you generate using
the other tools
and so let's dive in a little bit to the
real or the ones that we're focusing on
the session today so bigquery geospatial
actually a little bit of a Nostalgia
trip for me I was actually lucky enough
to be the product manager who launched
bigquery geospatial at this very
conference I think In This Very Room six
years ago since then we've continued to
invest to expand more functions and more
capabilities inside of bigquery
geospatial so that it does more and more
for you
so we were the first Cloud at that time
to have geospatial support and obviously
we continue to lead with our continued
investment
the thing that that investment in by
implementing this in bigquery what that
really gets you is
data catalog
scalable storage and this is what
massive compute gets you things just go
really fast especially geospatial
queries inside of bigquery so this is an
example of a pretty significant Geo join
and so this join is basically asked the
question how many land Parcels in Texas
have impervious surfaces so you're
taking a 12 million row table joining it
again with a 12 million row table the
answer has 4 million rows and Cloud SQL
this takes more than half a day it's
12.1 seconds in bigquery we see this
kind of stuff all the time this is not
unusual I did not cherry pick this
result as a matter of fact I think
Jeremy is gonna Jeremy is going to talk
about some of his experience with this
kind of performance boost so that's what
you get out of bigqueries capability
here
let's dive in about as briefly to Earth
engine
Earth engines got these three primary
pillars of differentiation the first one
I mentioned before the data catalog so
Earth engine's data catalog is more than
70 petabytes big and more than a
thousand different geospatial data sets
that are analytics ready
so for example let's say you wanted to
do an analysis over landsat images over
the last 40 years that's including all
of the relevant images is one line of
code in Earth engine the Earth engine
team has built a pipeline that collects
it from the satellite does all of the
pre-processing ready so that's just
ready to go in your analysis
um storage and computation we'll talk
about that one a little bit when Martin
and Jeremy come up the thing I wanted to
also dive into is that Earth engine has
been in the market for non-commercial
use for more than a decade and over that
time they have built an outstanding and
impressive user Community user Community
gets together in events like this but
specifically focused on Earth engine and
there are 91 000 monthly active users in
their community that means if you're new
to it there is a big repository of
willing helpers to help get you rolling
okay the last one the last pillar that I
wanted to talk about is one that's
actually growing here a cup this has
this pillar of Partners has grown
remarkably in the last two years
and so if you want to do some of this
work if you don't have a PhD in
geospatial analytics that's fine you
don't need it but you might want to have
somebody with that qualification on
speed dial and that's what you can get
from the partner Network so Partners
help with expert Consulting a number of
our partners uh so carto climate engine
acclima woza several of them up here
have also built bespoke Solutions on top
of the earth engine and bigquery
and when they've they've done that
customers like yourselves and the
partners
sorry just waiting for the truck to go
by
um
so customers and partners have asked us
for a couple primary things over the
last half decade of these pieces being
out in the marketplace number one is
more capabilities inside the
products and number two is better
interoperability because when a when a
partner or a customer Builds an
application generally it starts with
whatever the problem definition is that
middle circle there is signifying tying
several different pieces of the Google
Cloud platform together to generate the
solution and then exposing the solution
either through a map Google Cloud Google
Maps platform or through an API but that
process of tying several things together
can be difficult and then it can be
difficult to maintain so we heard that
feedback and our investments over the
last couple years have been to really
dive into interoperability between all
of these pillars in addition to adding
new capabilities
so
covered the suite covered the investment
thesis now I get to hand it off for the
really fun part where Emily gets to come
up here and tell you what fruits those
Investments are bearing
so much Chad so I'm Emily Schechter I'm
a product manager on Google Earth engine
theme
so Chad mentioned that one of the ways
we think about building an industry
leading sustainability platform is by
taking an integrated view across
multiple geospatial Platforms in TCP so
I'm really excited today to announce two
new connectors that make using these
tools together even easier
so first I'll talk about using bigquery
and Earth engine together and what we've
done to make that easier
so as Chad mentioned Earth engine and
bigquery share a common goal to make
large-scale data processing accessible
and as usable by as wide range of people
and applications
Earth engine is fantastic for roster
data processing like imagery whereas
bigquery is optimized for processing
large tabular data sets and is already a
critical part of many cloud data
analytics workflows
but by using bigquery and Earth engine
together customers can accomplish tasks
that are impossible on any other system
so to help people use these tools
together we built an easy to use
function to export tables from Earth
engine to bigquery and we're thrilled to
announce that this is now generally
available to use and there's a great
blog post out on the cloud blog that
describes how to use it
so the new connector is our first major
step towards deeper interoperability
between Earth engine and bigquery
improving ease of use for workflows that
use both Services enabling new analyzes
that combine raster and tabular data
so many of you may have tried to do this
before and it involved a few steps so by
creating the data connectors between
bigquery and Earth engine we collapse
these steps into a single command and
since those middle steps were really
data engineering data wrangling and not
analysis
we've not only made this process easier
but we're also enabling you to spend
more of your time on your valve Bill
science and Analysis
so for example let's say you were doing
some kind of crop yield prediction for
agriculture so your workflow might now
look something like this
first you use Earth engine to calculate
biomass from some satellite imagery or
maybe entire continents you bring that
data over to bigquery use a new
connector and you now can continue your
analysis in bigquery for example by
doing a geospatial join with some other
data that you already have in bigquery
or by using something like bqml to
create a model that predicts next year's
crop yield
so we're really excited that this
feature is now generally available and
we can't wait to see how you drive
sustainability impact with it
so next I'll talk about what we've been
focusing on in terms of machine learning
and interoperability with Earth engine
and vertex AI
so while machine learning has been in
use for remote sensing applications for
decades and it's been a core part of
what people do in Earth engine for a
long time
thinking about that integrated view of
geospatial analytics on GDP meant we
really had a critical opportunity to
bring together Earth observation imagery
from Earth Engine with the easy ability
to train and deploy deep learning models
in vertex AI
so Earth engine previously had an
integration with Cloud AI platform for
deep learning and since vertex AI is
superseding Cloud AI platform we wanted
to both integrate with the new platform
and also solve a number of pain points
that we heard about the old Earth engine
and Cloud AI platform connector
so we're super excited to launch our new
vertex AI connector to public preview so
you can now take your pixels from Earth
engine and fire them into all types of
models on vertex
so the way this works is that you take
imagery from Earth engine out to cloud
storage you train your model on vertex
AI post your model
and then do predictions with this new
Earth engine and vertex connector
we have a technical blog post we have
documentation and we have example
notebooks that are all posted online for
you to check out and get started
so we're really excited about both new
ways that you can use geospatial data to
unlock sustainability insights across
our geospatial Cloud products
and we have today two of our awesome
customers to talk more about their
experiences using these products to
generate sustainability impacts so first
we'll have Martine from Bayer crop
science talking about how they've
applied Earth engine and bigquery
together to power r d changes which is
especially important to understand how
food production needs change as our
climate changes and then we'll have
Jeremy from Clear Channel talking about
using geospatial insights with AI to
drive sustainability Focus impact
so without further Ado here is Martin
from bear crop science thank you Emily
um hi thanks everybody for taking the
time I know there's a lot of sessions
and um it might be a little bit hard to
um hear but I'll do my best um so I'm
Martin Mendez Constable I'm the vice
president of analytics and data for uh
mentioned those around the crop science
and what I want to do today is to show
you uh how we're using these products
this technology is uh likely as child
was saying are starting to be more
connected across each other right
um maybe as a little bit of a background
when we talk about vegetables r d in
club science one of our
core missions is around sustainability
deliver digital solutions that influence
sustainable products products meaning
vegetables ripe tomatoes peppers
cucumbers and so on that we sell
um globally as well so in order to do
that we obviously have a very robust r d
pipeline that requires us to generate a
lot of data geospatial data in nature
most of it
um and in a global nature as well
um I'm not intending to bore you do that
with you know breeding concept here but
you you can think about it this way so
you have if it's a tomato you have the
parents and you're gonna breed them
you're gonna come up with a new type of
tomato and you're gonna put that seed of
a tomato in the hands of Growers all
over the world where you're gonna test
them right so are those uh better than
the seeds that we're selling now are
they more sustainable sustainable uh
environmentally friendly do they consume
more or less water do they have better
flavor better shape better colored you
know a million things that you're gonna
characterize and measure right and a lot
of that is is truly sure special data
and data that is collected once you put
the seeds on the ground in Trials around
the trials all over the world thousands
of plots that are planted all over the
world in about 20 different vegetable
crops in an annual basis where you're
going to collect more and more data and
then hopefully use that data to
uh Advance some of those products to the
commercial phase right so
one of the challenges we had on in any
big corporations this is a unique obeyer
is how fragmented our ecosystem is in
terms of data and when we started
talking to Emily and chat about using uh
Google Earth engine and bigquery
together
this was one of our our premises right
can we actually stop moving data around
so much and
um disclaimer our club science Warehouse
is built on bigquery already so that was
a decision the Bayer Club science made a
few years back where we are bringing all
our data into a single Warehouse built
on top of bigquery so
um same as Chad maybe I'll share a
little bit of a trip into memory lane
for the last 15 20 years I've been um
chasing down the product team to
understand how we can use Google
retention more connected to Google Earth
engine right so how can we integrate
this data now that we have the connector
that Emily uh presented we've been using
it already as part of this project
and that will advance
our mission uh greatly right we will
stop basically moving data from all over
the place we have now the native
integration between Google retention and
bigquery and then we can use bigquery ML
and advanced analytics on top of both
um so in a way you can think about the
data catalog that Chad and Emily
presented and we definitely like to
leverage all the data source data layers
that are there already
um and in conjunction with
um bigquery and Google attention right
so we run all our models train them
validate them and then using the Google
Earth engine visualization options we
can enable our end users breeders
members of our testing teams all over
the world to see the result of this
analytical models right so this isn't
just you know our stock in our IDs or
like that or models or whatever is
people actually seeing the insights
coming out of those models in this case
the mo the map that you see there on
that side basically a representation of
different environments within California
we have used basically all the
environmental layers that are available
in Google retention and we have brought
all our data from bigquery and we have a
split basically different environments
according to how suitable they are for
multiple different crops let's say
tomatoes peppers cucumbers and so on Now
by using these platforms to charge
points that are scalable you can do that
real time globally right so no longer
you can do it in California but you can
do it across the globe on every single
country where we are doing business
where we're testing this vegetable seeds
um am I doing so you can imagine the
advantages it used to be very time
consuming and very paper based right now
It's All Digital
mom on top of that there's a lot of
different features that we like about
Google retention I'll just mention one
of them which is data Fusion capability
in the days of uh you know 10 10 years
ago for maybe some of you that are as
old as me you'll remember having to put
all the data together and start to agree
that to some sort of common cell size
and then creating all these derivatives
of data storing them and then coming up
with an output of it right so that
that's no longer needed because with
this data Fusion feature now we can do
real time on the flight greeting we
don't we don't end up creating so much
more data that nobody's going to use and
this actually takes two lines of code in
Google retention you used to take you
know a data scientist hours and hours
and hours of coding and you end up
creating a lot of data that was going to
waste anyway now with a handful of lines
of code we can do this real time and
have this output all
um we like to use the Uber concept of a
hexagon grids so we like to use the H3
indices to um to grid all these data to
a common a common cell size
now let's look at it how the impacts our
business right because this isn't just r
d for the sake of the doing data science
but we do want to end up impacting our
business so we are we have a very robust
number one pipeline in in the world when
it comes to vegetables r d we had to
create more products that Growers would
want whether it's better tasting
tomatoes or you know more sustainable
um bell peppers because they use less
water or they're more resistant to a
particular Pest and disease you know we
have to keep advance in our pipeline
right
putting all these things together now we
have the advantages of the data catalog
the processing the modeling and all this
visualization now this colors that you
see on this map of Italy are the same
concept of environmental clustering as
we call it applied to a very different
geography before it was California now
it's Italy now also you can look across
countries right so you can see what
tomatoes are better suited for Italy
versus California and maybe there's a
particular cultivar or hybrid that
applies to both that can perform very
well in both that's not always the case
but just to give you an example now and
you can run it like I said before across
every single country in the world very
very fast then you can influence Your
shermoplasm Design right so in the
example you have cauliflower you know
some people like white cauliflower
yellow cauliflower purple cauliflower a
smaller head a bigger hair you can use
all that data that is collected across
all the trials that we're running
and inform basically our pipeline
Advanced products that are not just more
sustainable but the consumers are
seeking more right and ultimately you
can also use digital phenotype in all of
these Technologies put together
influence where we deploy sensors on the
field on our r d trials do not just not
look at things and access color but now
measure color with sensors on the ground
right whether it's a UAV or a sensor
mounted on on a small robot inside a
greenhouse or an open field trial you
can put it all together and you can mine
all this data in ways that we could
never dream of
I'm gonna stop there and I'm gonna give
now
um the word to share me so he can walk
you through how they are implementing
Google Earth engine and bigquery thank
you
hi everyone can you hear me
hi everyone
my name is Jeremy Flynn I'm the senior
vice president of data products and
strategy at Clear Channel outdoor where
I oversee audience and measurement
solutions to run effective out of home
advertising campaigns so yes you get to
hear from a billboard guy out of cloud
conference
at Clear Channel I build audience
solutions that match the right location
with the right audiences to build the
best performing out of home audience
plans possible
you probably have seen our ads no matter
how you got to this conference whether
you landed at SFO or Oakland or San Jose
where you drove up the 101 or outside
the Moscone Center where you walked in
today we have thousands of advertising
ad units in the city of San Francisco
and my hope for today is you ever you
never not notice them after this session
right now
our industry the adipo industry is
making deep commitments towards becoming
more sustainable whether that is putting
solar panels on top of our bus shelter
ad units to reduce our Reliance on the
grid or making the slow conversion to a
hundred percent digital Billboards we're
deeply committed to reducing the time
effort and materials that go into
getting an out of home ad campaign live
and and for all of you that might mean
the world becoming a little bit more
like Minority Report or Blade Runner but
hopefully with a happier ending
today we're starting to see much more of
an intersection between Brands promoting
a sustainable message and the marketing
and business outcomes they're looking to
drive at the board level that Chad
referenced earlier CMOS are in those
board meetings and they're being asked
to promote the sustainable efforts of
the brands that they work for
and I believe that effective advertising
when done right through the power of
influence could actually build a more
sustainable world
this happens when you can drive
sustainable consumer behavior and action
over a long period of time
um I think a lot of you are about to
remember this but I'm a child of the 90s
and I really remember that got milk
advertisement that I saw literally all
over the place on TV on billboards in my
school library and now as adults I I've
realized how powerful that simple
message was in driving towards mass
action and how we need to start doing
that today with respect to
sustainability and climate action
so for advertising to be most effective
that means aligning the creative or
advertising message with the right place
the right time the Right audience and
that right place normally is the right
location so an effective advertising
strategy
um means that like we have an ability to
understand where to place the right ads
at the moment of families deciding to
make a more sustainable choice we also
do this for governments as Chad
mentioned earlier it's hot we actually
partner with a lot of local governments
towns municipalities to actually promote
sustainable messages and call to actions
during times of natural disasters
whether that be advising people to
evacuate during floods or during
upcoming heat waves we are there and at
the ready because we exist in the Public
Square on the other hand with respect to
Consumer purchase we actually work with
Brands to promote the sustainable
products that they're bringing to Market
and increasingly we see a statistically
significant increase in household
purchases of these more sustainable
products that can mean meatless uh
meatless uh Brands where we promote them
right outside of the grocery stores
where they could be purchased or more
sustainable Automotive vehicles that
we'd all love to see more of out on the
roads today
at Clear Channel we productize this
geospatial data through our radar
analytics Suite one to modernize
literally the oldest advertising medium
in the world and two to make the world
more sustainable
that might seem like a Bitty Pretty bold
Proclaim from a billboard guy but I'll
tell you how we're doing with that data
one of the products in our suite is our
radar view product which I'm about to
demo and we this is an insights platform
that is built on top of Google bigquery
Google vertex and one of our our
strategic Partners cardo that that
combines demographic data behavioral
data audience location location and
proximity data to build the best
performing out of home campaigns and
something that Chad also mentioned
earlier speed actually drives
performance enablement not just for the
successful out of home campaigns that
we're building but to truly
revolutionize the business practices or
the workflows of our sales teams trying
to sell those out of home ad campaigns
but a major problem with all of that
data is that there are millions and
millions of possible combinations and
the options to build a plan then become
Limitless and so that creates
bottlenecks it creates bottlenecks for
people who we want to use our products
to turn around media plans that we want
to be selling to Brands and advertisers
so that's where Google and cardo come in
using their technology we're able to
create even more self-service based
campaigns where we've introduced
conversational artificial intelligence
and natural language of processing to
actually increase the speed and
turnaround times of the types of media
plans that we're trying to create this
combination of Google bigquery with
vertex AI helps us produce actionable
location intelligence and audience
insights that ultimately helps us build
and and drive more successful out of AD
campaigns let's uh look at it in
practice so I'm gonna take a second to
run the video
by adding Google bigquery and vertex
running native within our radar View
application we can produce geospatial
Analytics
where we can first show all of our
Billboards on the map and then we can
actually add in an audience in this case
we want to drive an audience uh who
might be in the market for buying an
electric vehicle
stand out to the side
and then for today's purposes we also
can isolate that exact media plan in the
city of San Francisco for hyper
location-based targeting to reach
consumers in the city who might want to
change out their car for a more
sustainable brand model
and so as this runs you could see the
locations or the ad units that we could
sell updating in real time and finally
we're able to add in a final proximity
filter which is the proximity of our ad
units to contextually relevant locations
in this case electric charging stations
that actually exist in the city of San
Francisco and here there are three major
ones
and as we zoom in on the map in a minute
you'll actually start to see those
locations pop up so now we understand
the ad units in context to the proximity
of those Vehicles understanding the
audience that are most likely to
actually purchase the product that we're
trying to advertise
okay
that's the video
and I was taught how to flip to the next
slide
here we go
you saw how fast that works and again
speed is a performance enabler but by
aligning the stack and having our radar
view products sit on top of cardo
sitting on top of Google vertex Ai and
sitting on top of Google bigquery we are
processing hundreds of millions of
records of data to surface the
actionable audience insights to build
the most performative out of home plan
and before we actually migrated to
bigquery
um we were working with multiple managed
cloud service providers and there was a
lot of timeouts Maps weren't rendering
and our sales team were not using data
on their media campaigns so we had
weaker campaigns after that we actually
saw a significant reduction in the
processing time like the example that we
saw earlier and now with over 300 sales
people on Clear Channel who've been
selling Billboards longer than I've been
alive across 30 markets we're helping
advertisers large and small locally
nationally internationally actually run
higher more performative campaigns and
hopefully as those campaigns become more
sustainable in nature
and those calls whether they be calls to
action or more sustainable products
being brought to Market like Martin is
doing we're helping to use geospatial
data to help make the world a better
place even if it's for advertising
so now I'd like to invite Martin uh oh
Chad chat up first and a few others
gotta leave it to the advertising guy to
have the perfect tagline for his uh for
his talk there so we're gonna we're
gonna switch to the wrap up here and
then we'll have time looks like we'll
have time for a couple of questions
um so I want to I just wanted to uh say
that for Emily and me right from the
product side the googlers who are
involved in sustainability either from
the product management engineering go to
market sales teams our jobs we view our
jobs
to deliver exceedingly performed and
exceedingly capable products that
interoperate exceedingly well together
so that you all can go build you so that
you all can go grapple with the
sustainability and geospatial problems
that you need to solve what's really
cool about that is that stuff that was
impossible
three four years ago is now totally
possible so I encourage you all to go
back and rethink some of the things that
you've been you know have that you've
had on the shelf that you haven't been
able to do because the tooling will
allow that to work now
um and so as you grapple with these
problems I'm really really excited to
see what Solutions you go ahead and
develop
um and then speaking to a couple of
Solutions in particular
foreign
side we're so excited that so many of
these Solutions
um especially a couple of them up here
really demonstrate the incredible
sustainability impact that customers are
having with Earth engine
um that's really driving change across
these critical problems of climate
change mitigation and climate resilience
all right so we are pretty much at the
end grab the app let us know what you
thought
thank you very much
foreign